willkommen im dschungel es fühlt sich
wirklich ein bisschen so an hier unter
den riesen tomaten bäumen
wenn du auch tomatenanbau ist und lust
hast das richtig richtig gut zu machen
dann bist du hier genau richtig ich
werde dir nämlich meine sieben besten
tipps zum tomaten anbauen verraten so
dass du richtig leckere gesunde und
ertragreiche tomaten in deinem hoch bild
auf dem balkon im garten oder im
gewächshaus anbauen kannst
[Musik]
und tipp nummer eins ist dass du immer
mehr tomaten anbauen solltest als du
eigentlich planst denn so hast du immer
einen puffer so kannst du immer sicher
sein dass du trotzdem noch genug ernte
ist auch wenn vielleicht einzelne
jungpflanzen nichts werden wenn
vielleicht die krautfäule zuschlägt und
deine tomaten dahinrafft bevor du
wirklich eine ernte bekommst das haben
wir alles schon durch und da hätte ich
mir gewünscht ich hätte noch ein paar
mehr pflanzen in petto gehabt und falls
doch alles gut geht dann kochst du
einfach die ernte überschüsse 1 macht
eine leckere tomatensoße daraus ist ja
auch alles wunderbar dazu kommt bald
übrigens auch ein video hier auf dem
kanal also gerne ein abo da lassen wenn
dich das interessiert ich habe auch noch
mehr tomaten tipps geplant dieses jahr
tipp nummer zwei ist dass du ab und zu
ein paar blätter von deinen
tomatenpflanzen entfernen sollte ist die
sollten nämlich schön luftig wachsen
das sollten keine blätter den boden
berühren das ist ganz wichtig auch um
der krautfäule oder braunfäule
vorzubeugen
da also immer die blätter entfernen die
zu nah am boden sind oder die den boden
sogar berühren das sollte nicht
passieren aber auch wenn deine pflanzen
einfach sehr bissig sind sehr übermäßig
viele blätter haben dann mal
zwischendurch einen arzt oder zweier
ausbrechen das ist wichtig dass man die
pflanze nicht überfordert also ich mache
nie mehr als drei erste und 3 guides
triebe am stück ab an den
tomatenpflanzen weil ich ja nicht möchte
dass die probleme bekommt dadurch aber
dadurch dass die pflanzen ein bisschen
luftiger hältst bleiben sie viel länger
gesund weil ganz viel luft zwischen den
pflanzen zirkulieren kann weil die
pflanzen gut abtrocknen wenn sie mal
nass werden im regen oder hier im
gewächshaus auch schwitzwasser
abbekommen
dann können sie viel besser abtrocknen
wenn hier eine gute luftzirkulation her
das ist wirklich super wichtig bei
tomaten egal ob draußen oder drinnen und
in dem zuge vielleicht auch ganz gut zu
wissen wenn deine pflanzen krank sind
das heißt wenn das schon braunfäule an
den blättern ist oder irgendetwas
anderes ansteckendes dann packt die
blätter nicht auf den kompost ich habe
dafür einen kompost wo sich unkraut und
kranke pflanzenteile draufpacken der es
irgendwo einen entlegenen gartenecke und
den verwende ich dann später nicht mehr
in meinen
gemüsebeeten so dass sich die krankheit
dann nicht über den kompost auf die
neuen pflanzen die der nächstes oder
übernächstes jahr pflanzen möchtest
überträgt der dritte tipp ist dass du
deine tomatenpflanzen immer so gut
geschützt wie möglich an bauen sollte
ist das ist der grund warum wir dieses
gewächshaus haben
es hat noch mehr gründe dass wir das
haben aber das ist einer der hauptgründe
bei tomaten einfach nicht gerne nass
werden und man kann ja man kann nie so
genau sagen wie der sommer wird
natürlich waren die letzten beiden
sommer sehr sehr trocken und es hat kaum
geregnet jetzt gerade haben wir auch
einen eher trockenen sommer aber der
sommer davor
er war super nachts und da sind unsere
tomaten ich glaube im juni oder juli
schon komplett abgestorben gewesen weil
sie überhaupt keine chance hatten gegen
die braunfäule und das ist einfach super
schade
deswegen bauen wir unsere tomaten am
liebsten natürlich im gewächshaus an da
kann man auch schon viel früher pflanzen
wir sind da ungefähr einen monat früher
als draußen was du machen kannst ist
deine töpfer am haus anzubauen wir haben
da einfach ein paar töpfe direkt an die
hauswand geschoben
durch den kleinen dachvorsprung sind die
schon super gut geschützt und kriegen
auch wenn es stark regnet kaum etwas
dabei so das funktioniert auch sehr sehr
gut und bevor wir im gewächshaus hatten
haben wir so ganz viele tomaten angebaut
natürlich an der südseite des hauses
aber tomaten wachsen auch super gut im
topf und sind da bei uns zumindest immer
sehr sehr gut geschützt gewesen dann ist
es ganz wichtig dass du deine tomaten
regelmäßig dünnes tomaten sind richtig
hungrige pflanzen und das war mein
größter fehler als anfänger dass ich das
nicht wirklich ernst genommen habe meine
tomaten wann immer relativ klein sie
hatten immer gelbe blätter sie waren sie
waren ja nicht besonders ertragreich als
ich angefangen habe zu gärtnern weil ich
da wirklich nicht so wirklich drauf
geachtet habe ich habe die am anfang
einmal gedüngt und dann habe ich das
gelassen aber das reicht eben nicht man
muss auch während der wachstums saison
immer wieder nachdenken wenn du wissen
möchtest mit was ich dinge und wie oft
und wann und was man macht wenn ja wenn
die tomaten jetzt ein nährstoffmangel
anzeige
wie die hier dann schau dir gerne das
video da oben an da erkläre ich das
nämlich ganz genau ich verlege euch das
auch noch mal unten in der video
beschreibung wenn ihr erst hier fertig
schauen wollt dann könnt ihr sowieso
immer rein schauen da verlinke ich immer
videos die zu dem jeweiligen thema
passen könnten und die euch auch
interessieren könnten dann tipp nummer
fünf ich habe eben schon darüber
gesprochen ist es bei den aller aller
aller meisten tomatensorten wichtig dass
du sie aus geiz denn tomaten bilden
getriebe die wachsen immer hier seht ihr
jetzt nicht nur aber ich bin euch mal
einen idealen das ist ein ganz trieb und
den sollte man entfernen damit die
tomate nur einen trieb hat oder
höchstens zwei triebe hat manche bau und
ihr auch zwei kritik an so dass sie
trotzdem noch luftig stehen so dass die
die ganze energie in die früchte stecken
sie an dem einen haupt trieb wachsen und
einfach gesünder bleiben leichter
anzubauen sind und besser aus reifen es
hat ganz ganz viele vorteile die tomaten
auszug als nur weil busch tomaten macht
man das nicht da kam auch die frage wie
er kann ich dann ob es eine busch tomate
ist oder nicht also busch tomaten man
erkennt es ziemlich schnell wenn die
noch ganz klein sind sieht man keinen
großen unterschied aber bush tomaten
werden sehr schnell breiter als sie hoch
sind daran erkennt ja eigentlich
ziemlich schnell dass airbus tomate
anbaut ansonsten einfach auf die sorte
achten die ihr kauft oder wo ihre
saatgut verwendet wie das ganze genau
funktioniert mit dem ausreizen wie du
erkennst welche getriebe du entfernen
sollte ist ob man große betriebe auch
noch entfernen sollte und so weiter habe
ich alles in dem separaten video erzählt
dass es nochmal ein ausschweifender
liste über da könnte ich jetzt auch
stundenlang darüber reden aber schau dir
einfach das video da oben oder unten in
der video beschreibung
wenn du da mehr wissen willst zum
ausgleichen ansonsten habe ich euch ja
letztens den trick hier mit der
zahnbürste gezeigt und den möchte ich
hier auch noch mit aufnehmen wenn du ja
das ist einfach der geniale trick
überhaupt ohne witze ich bin total
begeistert davon wie gut das
funktioniert die zahnbürste vibriert so
ähnlich wie eine hummel oder eine biene
die auf der blüte landet und das ist
wichtig damit der pollen vom männlichen
teil der blüte in den weiblichen teil
transportiert wird und sich aus einer
blüte eine
oft entwickeln kann oft hat man aber
viel zu wenig insekten die an die
tomaten rangehen so dass ganz viele
blüten zwar blühen aber dann eine frucht
draus wird und deswegen ist es wichtig
dass man da nach hilft oder ist es nicht
wichtig die meisten leute machen das
nicht aber ich habe das letztes jahr
angefangen und enorm gute erfahrungen
damit gemacht also einfach mit der
elektrischen zahnbürste an eine blüte
gehen und die ein bisschen damit
behandeln so dass wir die insekten
simulieren können
dazu habe ich auch ein separates video
wo ich auch noch mal zeigen wie man das
von hand machen kann
das verlange ich auch da oben und da
unten habt ihr echt was zum anschauen
sind ihr die videos noch nicht geguckt
hat und dann ist es auch super wichtig
dass du im laufe der jahre
deine lieblings orten findet denn es
gibt tomaten in allen möglichen
geschmacksrichtungen in allen größen in
allen formen in allen farben es ist
total abgefahren was man darf wenn ihr
vielfalt hat und deswegen ist es finde
ich super super schön wenn man nach und
nach die lieblingssorten herausfindet
die einem richtig gut schmecken die ja
die man immer wieder anbaut und deswegen
ist es so so wertvoll und ich hab das
dieses jahr wirklich verkackt muss ich
ehrlich gesagt dass man sich auf
schreibt wie die sorten heißen die man
pflanzt und ich habe das gemacht aber
mit einem stift der mittlerweile
abgewaschen ist und der zwei sich nicht
mehr welche form ein tomaten welche
sorte ist also klar die sollten die
schon mal angebaut habe die ich besser
kenne die erkenne ich auch wieder nicht
viel mit ziemlich sicher dass das hier
zucker trauben sind aber so ganz genau
weiß ich es erst wenn ich sie probiere
das ist einfach schade weil ich habe
auch viele neue sorten ausprobiert
dieses jahr und ich weiß jetzt ehrlich
gesagt überhaupt nicht mehr wie die
heißen welche das sind ich glaube dass
hier in batterien oder die habe ich
jetzt auch zum ersten mal angebaut kann
es sein dass die sonne party gefunden
hat ich weiß gar nicht genau aber ich
würde das gerne und das ist einfach
schade das ist etwas was mir dieses jahr
echt sauer aufgestoßen ist dass ich das
so verbockt habe und deswegen möchte ich
das hier noch mal einfügen es ist super
wichtig dass man sich merkt wie die
sorten
weil dann kann man im nächsten jahr
nochmals zurückgehen und dieselben
sorten nochmal anbauen natürlich kann
man auch saatgut von den pflanzen nehmen
das ist dann auch ziemlich sicher dass
man eine sorte rhein weiter vermehrt das
ist sehr sehr selten dass sich sorten
untereinander kreuzen
aber es ist trotzdem schön zu wissen wie
die sorte heißt oder wenn ihr wollt dass
ich mal ein video zum saatgut nehmen
mache dann schreibt das gerne mal unten
in die kommentare
das muss man ja fermentieren damit man
das saatgut von dem kleber befreien kann
da kann ich euch gerne mal zeigen wie
ich das mache ich habe euch alle meine
tomatenanbau tipps in einem pdf
zusammengefasst dass ihr euch gerne
kostenlos runterladen könnt den weg
packe ich euch unten in die video
beschreibung ansonsten verliere ich euch
hier drüben meine playlist mit meinen
ganzen tomaten videos die ich hier schon
auf youtube gepostet habe und da unten
findet ihr auch noch ein video das euch
interessieren könnte wir sehen uns
nächste woche wieder biss dann tschüss
irgendwas krabbelt in meinem augen
außerdem sitzt ich gerade auf keller
sind es tut mir unglaublich leid